okay let's get more should we now on the
politics of the day with the leader of
the lib dems davey hi it's good to see
you thank you for joining us on the
programme the prime minister is in india
let's start there then should we first
of all and then move on to partygate
should we be doing business with a
country that is supporting russia during
the war in ukraine we should be talking
to them and telling them not to and
asking them not to but india is a very
important ally for the united kingdom
and the west and will only pull them
away from russia if we engage with them
and india has been one of our friends my
concern is that the prime minister keeps
doing really bad trade deals that
actually aren't good for our country uh
he's letting down farmers he's letting
down
businesses laying down people and
workers and i just worry that he'll
conclude a bad deal
um is it not undermining sanctions
though by buying oil from russia in
rupees
well i think we should stop buying uh
oil and gas and whether it's
particularly the indians but india and
germany i mean there are um european
countries who should stop uh funding
putin
and i've argued when i was secretary of
energy and climate change that we should
take away
the fossil fuels from our energy system
as quickly as possible and there are
countries like germany
in the european union who
haven't moved as fast as we have are on
renewables and i would urge them to do
that okay talk to me about partygate
then um
we had the minister sitting where you
are a couple of hours ago and he was
basically saying yes we will the prime
minister of course will allow the
privileges committee to look into what
has happened around partygate and
whether he misled parliament or not but
it has to be due process we need to get
the other two investigations ended first
well i think it's wrong this is actually
all about
um breed families it's all about the
people who lost their loved ones who
kept the rules and they saw the person
who
wrote those rules not obeying them he's
been fined it's really clear that he
misled parliament
when that happens the due process it
goes straight to the privileges
committee no delays no um obfuscation
and the last time the conservatives
tried to do this and mess up the rules
and not follow due process was the owen
patterson scandal what happened there
was a by-election a party by election in
north shropshire and the liberal
democrats gave the conservatives a
beating in a seat they had held for 200
years you know voters feel that this
conservative government is taking them
for granted they think that they can get
away with things that are above the law
well they're not and what i say to
conservative mps today is you should
vote for the prime minister go straight
to the privileged committees and he's
not above the law
he agrees that he's not above the law uh
the government agrees that he's not
above the law but it's about your
process i don't trust this prime
minister and just a word he says
and it was very interesting that the
british people were polled at 200
representative sample at the weekend and
the word most commonly used by far about
the prime minister was liar and when you
have a country in crisis with the cost
of living emergency with the
international crisis
we need a leader that people can trust
we need leadership we need judgment we
need people to have confidence in the
decisions and i don't think the evidence
is that people have any more confidence
in them and so that's why conservatives
should do their patriotic duty and get
this man out and if they don't
well i think they're guilty they're
guilty by association and i say to your
viewers that if the conservative mps
won't do the right thing do their
patriotic duty and vote this man out of
office then on may the 5th of the local
elections
many many people across our country will
have the have the ability to send a
message that boris johnson should go so
why not wait for that then instead of
taking up parliamentary time with a vote
that's obviously not going to go
anywhere because i want a government i
want a cabinet i want a prime minister
who will help people
we've got a government that is failing
many other countries around the world
are helping people with their energy
bills with the cost of living our
government this conservative government
are raising taxes they're making a
difficult situation even worse and
they're also choosing unfair taxes they
hit the lowest paid and liberal
democrats are saying that is wrong we
should help people now we should have
tax cuts so i've argued for a curtain
vat
that would be worth the average family
600 pounds a year that's the size of the
help that will begin to make a real
difference for people who are struggling
you know of course that the prime
minister is in india we just got a
picture in of him actually just as was
chatting to i mean it literally
literally is a headline writer's dream
to me it looks as though he's spinning
yarn
yeah well this is a man who spins
everything
you know that's another one they'll use
yeah i mean the thing is
as i said the british people don't trust
this man
and i think that's very serious for our
our politics we need integrity back
we need justice back we need fairness
back and i'm afraid he doesn't stand for
that he he's out of touch
and you know whether it was in the
by-election cheshire true blue blocking
show where little democrats beat the
conservatives all north shops that i
mentioned earlier where liberal
democrats beat the conservatives we talk
to lifelong conservative voters they
don't see him as decent he spins his way
out of things well i think time has
caught up with him and i think lifelong
conservative voters are switching away
and in many parts of the country they're
switching to the liberal democrats we'll
see we'll see um it's good to talk to
you as well thank you thank you very
much indeed for joining us